[Music]
so you know they say when you really
love something you don't go easy on it
you actually critique it more because
you want it to be better and you have
higher expectations for it because you
want it to be so good so i've already
made a dear youtube video where i talked
about
some of the qualms i had with youtube
and the experiments they were running
and the weird stuff they were doing with
thumbnails a little while ago
you guys might not know this but after
that video they reached out to me
they listened
and they reacted and youtube's one of
the only platforms that actually does
that that listens to their creators
and actually does things about it so
that's why i wanted to talk about this
new thing that's come up which is
removing public dislikes so there was a
youtube blog post yesterday with a video
explaining that they will be slowly
hiding the dislike counter for all
videos on youtube starting today so the
dislike count information will still be
available to the uploader in the back
end but that dislike count will now be
hidden for all viewers of all videos and
i don't think that's a good move i think
there are more downsides than upsides to
this now youtube they have their reasons
and we'll go over each of them because
they were very clear about why they're
doing this but something to keep in mind
here
context matters like we have to remember
what youtube is so the reason for this
that they're citing the most and i'll
just take their word for it is that
first of all public dislike counters can
impact creators well-being and it can
also enable targeted dislike campaigns
on certain videos and so there's a
pretty simple three-minute video from
matt koval at youtube explaining
youtube's thinking and how it came
directly from some of the smaller
experiments they've run and the findings
from youtube's research teams now
removing information from the site
isn't totally unheard of uh you've
probably seen instagram is giving some
users the ability to remove public like
counts from posts that's already
happening and some of you
might be
old enough to remember
when youtube itself here was on a 5 star
rating system so every video you could
rate one two three four or five stars
and it would show you the average rating
under the video they switched from that
to the current like dislike system
around 2010
and it's technically less information
but it was fine because here's the thing
about the like and dislike count when
you put them together it forms a ratio
and that ratio is the immediately
glanceable piece of information that i
can look at when i arrive on a video to
know if it's going to be worth my time
to watch it or not and that that little
glanceable thing is super useful in lots
of context so if i if i show up here to
watch uh
a home improvement video how to install
a new smart doorbell and i click on a
video about it and the first video i
select has uh five dislikes and 20
dislikes
that little glanceable red flag is my
cue to scroll down to the comments
section to find out just like that you
know oh they they installed this one
incorrectly or this is an older version
of the doorbell or the install didn't
work something like that okay backing
out onto the next video or if i'm on
here looking for a way to fix something
or learn something then arriving at a
video with a high dislike ratio lets me
know that this video probably won't do a
good job of helping me fix the thing or
learn the thing and if i'm on here
looking to be entertained basically the
like to dislike ratio can help me
possibly determine if this video will be
entertaining fun to watch or not so that
like to dislike counter isn't always
just an indicator of the quality of the
video but it's more of a review of your
experience watching the video whether
it's satisfied which you came for the
video for or not
and that's all with the given context so
when you hide the dislike counter
it's no longer a ratio and basically you
hide a very useful piece of information
to determining if a video is worth
spending your time watching or not now
matt makes an interesting point in
youtube's official video
that other platforms don't have a
dislike button honestly i think you're
going to get used to it pretty quickly
and keep in mind other platforms don't
even have a dislike button so this is
technically true
but i don't think that's the best way to
think about this mainly because when
they're talking about other platforms i
think they're referring to the
facebooks and instagrams and tick tocks
of the world so those other platforms
might not have a dislike button but the
thing is youtube
isn't like those other platforms those
other platforms are mostly content
recommendation engines
where youtube is also a massive search
engine so if you are comparing to
tick tock or twitter one of these sites
sure there's no dislike button on these
sites but there is always still some
version of a way to give feedback to the
algorithm to decide what content to
surface so
likes
comments shares
people getting ratioed whatever it's all
happening
facebook i don't know if you really want
to be like facebook but youtube is not
just a video recommendation engine it's
also the second largest search engine in
the world behind google so this uh
feedback that we give content isn't just
for
surfacing it through a recommendation
engine but it's also to sort of
understand if people are having a good
time
while they're on the site so youtube is
we already know they're always tweaking
their algorithms and their features and
the ui even
with the general goal of making sure
people have a good time on the site so
that they stay here longer that's what
they're ideally they're gonna have
people stay on the site for many hours
in a row and they'll watch lots of
videos and as a result watch lots of ads
and make them lots of money so generally
they're gearing this to make sure we
have a good time on youtube.com so to me
hiding dislikes
actually hurts the experience of the
vast number of people
using youtube as a search engine because
it removes that glanceable bit of
information that was going to help you
decide if the thing you just landed on
was worth spending your time on or not
so instead of looking at uh tick tock
and instagram youtube really feels more
like
netflix
or
amazon or etsy even because you get to
the site there's this huge thing at the
top it's a search bar and so when you
get to the piece of content you're
looking for there is a way for you to
review if that piece was what you were
looking for or not if it's good or not
and so that's the like or dislike ratio
like can you imagine if etsy got rid of
one star ratings to protect the mental
health of its sellers and to combat
review bombing
like it would work but it would also
decrease the usability of the entire
site so the only difference is on etsy
you're trying to decide where to spend
your money and on youtube you're trying
to decide where to spend your time so
you might not hear a ton of creators
saying it but i'm here for the dislike
button and the public dislike count now
as a creator i can agree
that the dislike counter
racking up in front of you and in front
of everybody over time can be mentally
taxing
but i also think that's something you
put less and less weight on over time
and then i also think hiding the public
counter
just removes that scoreboard but then
also leaks all of that negativity into
the comments section which is worse
right like the comment section on
youtube is already where most of the
mental health
conversations i think happen when i talk
to other creators and you know there's
already some tools that they've built
you know they can you can block people
of course but you can hide others from
your channel you can assign moderators
to your comments section you can filter
out certain words so that they aren't
allowed to be used in the comments they
get hidden automatically
but they still have a long way to go we
all know about youtube comments and so
if i think they put their energy
towards that they could make a bigger
dent a bigger difference towards the
mental health of creators than just
blanket erasing the public like dislike
count now there is no video on youtube
with like a lot of views and zero
dislikes there's always some people
disliking for whatever reason like
sometimes it's a news video with bad
news and people dislike the video
because they dislike the news even if
it's a good video sometimes it's a
political video and people on the
opposing side of the political aisle
dislike it because they just don't like
what you have to say but if a video is
getting overly disliked for no reason at
all essentially as a targeted attack
like a review bomb then yes there should
be ways to mitigate that and you know
you can already disable ratings entirely
on a video but maybe that means youtube
working on new tools for this specific
pretty small use case maybe there's like
you can have you can only rate the video
if you've watched a certain proportion
of it something like that so overall i
think you know this change that they're
making is well intentioned and i give
them credit for that because they are
thinking about creators but i think just
blanket removing the dislike count from
all videos on youtube does more harm to
the user experience
than problems it solves so we all
understand that dislike bombs are a
thing and we all know that the mental
health of creators is very important but
i do think a more nuanced solution
than just carpet removing the dislike
counter from every video would probably
work better but hey that's just my
opinion and maybe you agree maybe you
disagree matter of fact if you do agree
you can leave a like on this video if
you don't agree you can leave a dislike
that's how it's used sometimes we can
use the comments section to talk about
it and if youtube if you're watching
this maybe some creators will chime in
in the comments section below about what
we think
either way that's just been it thanks
for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
you